new revelations from the Muller
investigation a CNN commentator says an
anti-semitic thing and gets the boot and
we check the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show here it's
come Friday that's right we're here we
made it all the way through the week but
don't worry there's plenty of news to
get you through the weekend we will get
to all of it and I promise you the next
few weeks leading up to Christmas are
going to be insane because every day
since I don't know like four years agos
been crazy so that's not gonna let up
we'll talk about all of that in one
second but first let's talk about the
national debt 1.2 trillion dollars
that's what was added to the national
debt in fiscal year 2018 economists say
by the end of 2019 we'll be spending
more on the interest of our national
debt than we spend on Medicare by 2023
we'll be spending more on just the
interest than we spend on our military
as balloon payments become do you need
to ask yourself what the impact of the
US dollar is going to be what is the
impact on your investments and what is
your plan can you afford another hit to
your retirement like the last downturn
when the S&P dropped 50% it's worthwhile
to have some hedges in your portfolio
hedge against inflation hedge against
uncertainty and instability with
precious metals bold is a safe haven
against uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be as well
I'm not saying take all your money out
of the stock market dump it into
precious metals I'm saying take some of
your money and hedge against your bets
in the stock market with precious metals
the company I trust with precious metal
purchases is Birch gold group and right
now thanks to a little-known RS tax law
you can even move your IRA or eligible
401k into an IRA backed by physical gold
and silver which is perfect for people
who want to protect their hard-earned
retirement savings fremming from any
future geopolitical uncertainty look
back historically when the bottom falls
out of everything else gold tends to
safeguard savings Birch gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau it's the
holidays you get gives for everybody
else get one for yourself free the gift
of understanding what diversification
means contact Birch gold group got a
free information kit on physical
precious metals see if diversifying into
gold and silver make some sense for you
the comprehensive 16-page kit shows how
gold and silver can protect those
savings to get your no cost no
obligation kit go to birchgold.com slash
Ben that's birchgold.com slash Ben and
go check it out right now and make sure
that you are diversified again it
protects you against the vicissitudes of
life and the market birchgold.com /ban
the folks I trust
precious metals investing all right so
suffice it to say that the last 72 hours
have not been kind to President Trump
I've been a number of news items and I'm
gonna try and break them all down for
you today in a comprehensible fashion
because there's been so much news
breaking with regard to the Muller
investigation that it's hard to keep on
top of it and I know that you're hearing
two competing narratives two competing
narratives competing narrative number
one is the one you're hearing from the
left tomb is imminent for president
Trump's he will soon be impeached it's
all over it turns out that Michael Cohen
is going to spill the beans and he is
going to show us that presidents from
actively colluded with the Russians in
the election it's not this just that he
received information from WikiLeaks via
Roger stone or something it's gonna be
that he was actively working with the
Russians to militarize and weaponize
that information and that he suborned
perjury to do it that's claimed from the
lefties it were this close to
impeachment claim from the right from
people I respect is that this is
basically Robert Muller in over his head
that he's come up with no actual
evidence of criminality and so he is now
trying to create the illusion of
collusion on various other matters so
there's no actual criminal activity that
took place and thus all of these
ancillary topics really have very little
to do with the central contention of the
investigation that they oversold this
investigation and now Muller is
struggling to put together two and two
to make it equal five well I think there
is some truth to both of these and a lot
of falsehood to both of these my general
take is that the evidence is worse for
Team Trump than it was a week ago with
regard to their relations with Russia
it looks like President Trump may have
lied more than he did a week ago it
looks like more members of his orbit
have been complicit in working with
Russian sources at the same time the
idea that charges of criminality are on
their way you know actual criminal
collusion criminal conspiracy that still
seems incredibly far-fetched to me so it
could be ancillary charges of suborning
perjury it could be ancillary charges of
obstruction of justice those things
could be on the table but the central
contention still has been not based in
reality and I'm just gonna show you the
level of enthusiasm for folks on the
left for charges that have not yet been
proved and then we will get to the
actual charges so
you can see rachel maddow yesterday on
MSNBC she called into MSNBC and she said
that because Michael Cohen the
president's personal lawyer had pled
guilty to a charge of lying to Congress
that this was the beginning of the end
for a little Trump is Robert Muller
somehow throttled compared to how he
used to be able to conduct his
investigation and pursue prosecutions
related to this matter is he unable to
bring new indictments because Mount
Whitaker won't approve them if what
you're saying is true and the
investigation continues to be overseen
by Rosen Stein it just puts a very
different cast on this and I think it
makes it it actually makes me feel like
this must be a much more ominous moment
for the White House okay so she doesn't
know anything that makes it seem like a
much more ominous moment photometers Joy
Behar who of course is kind of the
stupid version of everyone on the left
she sort of shouts at things
so here's Joy Behar shouting that Trump
should resign why
but she should he should resign why
because she's drive a hard and she says
stuffing her face opens and sound comes
out today is a good day for Donald Trump
to resign I really believe that
[Applause]
today is a good day for him I struggle
to name a day the joy behar doesn't
think would be a good day for Donald
Trump to resign so let's try and
separate out all of the various strands
here so over the past 72 hours there
have been a bunch of things that have
happened the first thing that happened
Michael Cohen pled guilty to lying to
Congress about a Trump Organization
Russian business deal so on Thursday
Cohen pled guilty to lying to Congress
he talked about this yesterday about the
Russian investigation in a plea deal
with Robert Muller Cohen already pled
guilty in a Southern District of New
York case regarding alleged campaign
finance violations and making payments
to former Trump paramour stormy Daniels
earlier this year you remember that one
the allegation is that President Trump
had basically funneled personal funds
via Michael Cohen to stormy Daniels but
he didn't use his own money he had
Michael Cohen make an in-kind
contribution in order to stop stormy
Daniels from coming clean and this was
somehow a campaign finance violation
maybe maybe not that's what happened
earlier this year now
Cohen admitted he lied to Congress when
he said that the Trump organizations
attempt to set up a Trump Tower in
Moscow ended in January 2016 so he had
testified that in January 2016 from stop
talking about the Trump Tower in Moscow
before the end of the primaries and
before the general election Trump
himself had tweeted in the middle of
2016 that he had no business
relationships in Russia now the language
could be true even if he was in
negotiations for those business
relationships at the time and even if he
had negotiated with the Russians
regarding a Trump Tower in Moscow like
up to five minutes ago ironically enough
that tweet that people are citing the
one where Trump says I have no business
relationships in Russia that tweet could
be I think escaped by President Trump in
the exact same way that Bill Clinton
tried to escape a perjury charge when he
said that he had not had sex with that
woman Monica Lewinsky if you recall his
claim was that in present tense he was
not having sex with Monica Lewinsky and
then he was asked well you did in the
past
and he said right but it depends on the
definition of is right well this could
be the same thing you could have
President Trump saying right I don't I
said I don't have relationships with
business in Russia meaning like right
now but five minutes ago I did in any
case Cohen apparently
lied to Congress he says that he made
the false statements to be consistent
with individual ones political messaging
and to be loyal to individual one now
what this what this plea deal by Cohen
does not state is that President Trump
instructed him to do all of this right
President Trump could have been out
there saying listen I have no business
relationships in Russia and Cohen in
order to cover president Trump's ass
basically took matters into his own
hands and he said yeah yeah this all
ended back in January without Trump
actively informing him that he should
lie to Congress this does make a
difference because if you are suborning
perjury that was one of the charges that
was brought against Richard Nixon in his
impeachment case it was one of the
charges brought against Bill Clinton in
his impeachment cases what David French
and I were talking about before the show
this morning David of course writes for
National Review Cohen also admitted that
the Moscow project was discussed all the
way through June 2016 and that he
communicated directly with the office of
Vladimir Putin in January 2016
in September 2017 Cohen had explained
that he had nothing to do with any
Russian involvement in our electoral
process and never saw anything not a
hint of anything that demonstrated
Trump's involvement in Russian
interference in our election or any
other form of Russian collusion now
again those two statements could still
be true it could be that he was doing
business with Russia and that that does
not involve collusion because I guess
the theory of the case here is that
somehow if Trump was doing business in
Russia that this was a quid pro quo and
that Putin wanted to help him because he
was doing business in Russia
none of that has been proved at this
point like at all Trump for his part
denies working on the Moscow deal he
says that was a project that we didn't
do I didn't do is a project that wasn't
done for a lot of reasons I was focused
on running for president I wanted that
to be my primary focus not running or
building a building his ongoing business
relationship with Russia again would not
actively amount to criminal activity
this is what Jake Tapper on CNN pointed
out to the to a member of the Senate
Judiciary Committee Jerry Nadler
yesterday on CNN and that Democrat could
not explain how the Trump Tower attempts
to be built in Moscow had anything to do
with electoral hacking or election or
electioneering look at these documents
and I don't see any evidence of
conspiracy between members of the Trump
team and members the Russian government
to interfere in the election he's mixing
his personal business profits with
respect and perhaps putting them over
the in
the United States and food and and lying
to the electorate about it sure it
stinks I'm not I'm not saying that's not
conspiracy is all I'm saying
okay so in that what tapper is saying is
exactly right you can say that it stinks
right you can say that President Trump
you know signing business deals with
Russia are trying to do so in the middle
of an election where he's praising
Vladimir Putin that it that smells to
high heaven in the same way that it
smelled to high heaven when the Clinton
Foundation was taking all sorts of
donations from various and sundry
foreign nations who are suddenly getting
special treatment from the Hillary
Clinton State Department you can say it
stinks in the same way that Barack
Obama's administration stunk in terms of
Joe Biden and his family making a big
deal with the Chinese government
well Biden was vice president according
to Peter Schweitzer you can say all of
those things none of that is necessarily
criminal now President Trump went on
Twitter this morning he said oh I get it
I'm a very good developer happily living
my life when I say our country is going
in the wrong direction to put it mildly
against all odds I decide to run for
president and continue to run my
business very lagaa and Verico talked
about on the campaign trail lightly
looked at doing a building somewhere in
Russia put up zero money zero guarantees
and didn't do the project which hunt and
so this is the way that he is spending
this again that's a little bit different
from I didn't have any relationships and
Russia I didn't do business in Russia
they they have none that nothing is
happening here that that seems to be a
bit of an exaggeration at the very least
or a lie at the very most but that again
is not perjury because he has not
testified to any of that okay so that
was Story number one the the Michael
Cohen pleading guilty in saying that he
perjured himself in front of Congress
about the involvement of the Trump
family and Trump organization in a
business deal in Russia again that does
not amount to electoral collusion it
does not amount to election hacking it
doesn't amount to a quid pro quo it
doesn't amount to any of those things it
amounts to an ancillary crime that took
place after the campaign when Michael
Cohen was testifying before Congress and
it has a lot of people on the right
asking okay well we know James clapper
lied in front of Congress you know Eric
Holder was held in contempt of Congress
we know that a bunch of officials from
the Obama days lied in front of Congress
Hillary Clinton lied in front of
Congress on Benghazi for that matter we
know all of those things but none of
those people were prosecuted so is this
just an attempt by robert muller
to cram
down a crime on michael cohen to get him
to flip on trump the answer is maybe but
does that mean that trump is off the
hook
not necessarily two things can be true
at once one it's not fair that all those
other people went unprosecuted to
michael cohen may have lied to congress
three this actually does not mean that
trump colluded it does not support the
central charge that trump colluded and
conspiracy to hack the election in 2016
we'll get to some of the other news
events can trying to break this down for
you in a simple a fashion as possible
then we'll get to the latest updates but
first let's talk about what you are
going to get as a gift for somebody this
christmas or hanukkah
what's the worst or weirdest gift you
ever got it's an ugly sweater is it a
terrible fruitcake don't you wish that
that person had just given you cookies
instead because cookies are God's gift
to humanity
you know Benjamin Franklin said that
beer was proof that God loves us cookies
are the actual proof that God loves us
cookies are just bait listen I don't
have to pump how great cookies are this
is a proposition that should sell itself
why because mrs. Fields is now sponsor
on spur I could not be more excited
about this okay mrs. Fields a sponsor on
this program for over 40 years they've
made delicious treats like their
signature chocolate chip cookies which
are delicious handcrafted frosted
favorites melt in your mouth brownies
mrs. Fields many other products are
kosher this is why I'm so excited to
talk about mrs. fields I remember there
was a time when my wife and I were in
Buffalo New York and we did not have any
food in Buffalo New York and by the time
we got to the airport we were starving
what did we do we bought about 1,000
mrs. Fields Cookies and we survived on
those mrs. Fields Cookies for a full 12
hours and it was the happiest 12 hours
of our life because the food is great
mrs. field ordering is easy they can
ship your gift anywhere across the US
Plus you can add a personal touch with a
custom message company logo or family
photo mrs. fields even offers a 100%
customer satisfaction guarantee
they have gourmet tins gift tins and
baskets they make a perfect present this
year send a fresh-baked gift no one can
resist right now get 20% off your order
when you go to mrs. fields calm and
enter promo code Shapiro that's 20% off
any gift and mrs. fields calm promo code
Shapiro again mrs. fields calm promo
code Shapiro I should have to sell this
one to you it's cookies they're
delicious you send them people will give
you credit they will give you back a
cookie come on and you get 20% off when
you use promo code Shapiro mrs. fields
calm promo code Shapiro go buy some
cookies I mean come it's like the
easiest
in the world go check it out right now
mrs. fields calm and again use that
promo code Shapiro okay back to the
revelations of this week so revelation
number one was Michael cones testimony
he pled guilty to lying to Congress
about the Trump Tower in Moscow which
apparently was still being negotiated by
members of Team Trump up to and
including possibly Donald Trump jr. all
the way up to June 2016 to Muller's team
is now looking into president Trump's
phone calls with Roger stone right this
is another revelation we talked about
earlier this week but basically the idea
is this there is a chain of gossip that
goes from WikiLeaks to drum courses of
conspiracy theorists to Roger stone
another top political operative slash
conspiracy theorist to President Trump
and Trump is calling stone was getting
information from core see who's getting
information from WikiLeaks and basically
via this process Trump is saying to
stone something like you know what are
you hearing and stone saying well I'm
hearing from my good friend Jerry Corsi
the WikiLeaks is gonna dump some stuff
on Hillary's health maybe she talked
about Hillary's health and Trump's like
okay and then the next day he goes out
on the stump and he says Hillary let's
say she's gonna keel over okay that's
not collusion that is Trump operating
off rumored information not the same
thing as Trump actively militarizing
information with the help of the Russian
government in exchange for something
happening is it good no it's not good
but Hillary Clinton actually did do the
exact same thing during the 2016
election with regards to the Ukrainian
government which was providing her dirt
on Trump at the same time that was
reported by Politico at the time stone
denies any of his email conversations of
course he came up with Trump he says I
didn't actually talk with Trump about
the WikiLeaks stuff at all maybe maybe
not we'll see what Muller has okay
number three palm Anna for it had a plea
deal that fell apart this week okay that
plea deal basically suggested he was
going to turn on Trump he says he's no
longer going to do that Muller accused
him of lying to him and voided his plea
arrangement and Muller's Muller found
out that Manta force lawyers have been
coordinating with president Trump's
lawyers now that could actually be a
problem for Trump because if man affords
plea agreements voided the joint defense
agreement between Trump and man afford
than all of those negotiations all the
information that passed hands if Trump
was telling mana for its afib tomorrow
for example if any of that happen that
could now be subject to Muller scrutiny
so that could be very bad for
Trump in a second I want to tell you
about the consequences of this give you
the latest updates so here are the
latest updates that we have over the
last 24 hours
according to Axios they're reporting
what they think is going to come next
the Garrett graph writes a piece for
Axios talking about what he thinks is
going to happen now he says Michael
Cohen's lies to Congress fit an old pet
in odd pattern multiple people in
Trump's orbit have outright lied or
forgotten about a whole variety of
contacts with Russian officials
developers oligarchs and emissaries it's
uniquely consistent problem across many
top aides that only seems to occur when
the subject is Russia aces remember
Michael cones two major revelations so
far have come in just two fairly limited
specific episodes both of which
investigative reporters have unearthed
ahead of time stormy Daniels hush money
payments in the Moscow from tower
project
Cohen worked with Trump for decade what
else don't we know he says prosecutors
ethically can't let a witness testify or
pleaded things they don't believe are
true so everything Cohen is saying in
court for all the talk about they're
making Cohen lie Muller would then have
to be violating you know basic legal
conduct every twist of the investigation
shows that Muller knows far more than we
thought he did according to Axios Khan's
plea deal shows he has phone records the
aborted jerome corsi plea agreement
shows Muller has emails the fact that
Muller knows Paul Manafort was lying to
him likely indicates heretofore unseen
corroborating witnesses documents and
more so you know it's it's worth while
waiting at this point next in the
crosshairs probably probably is Donald
Trump jr. this is the the latest this is
sort of the the latest spin on this
according to ABC News the admission by
president from longtime personal
attorney Michael Cohen that he lied to
Congress about the Trump organizations
plans to build a Trump branded
skyscraper in Moscow which by the way
was supposed to have included like a 50
million dollar penthouse for Vladimir
Putin has brought new scrutiny upon the
sworn testimony of other Trump
associates including his oldest son
representative Adam Schiff the ranking
Democrat on the House Intelligence
Committee has called on the committee's
Republican leadership to accelerate the
release of transcripts from interviews
they conducted behind closed doors to
the special counsel and the public so
they could be analyzed for misleading
statements so it looks now like Schiff
is going to start targeting Democrats
are gonna start targeting everybody else
in Trump's orbit hoping that those
people will eventually flip on Trump or
Trump will be forced to pardon them or
that it from
and they will charge him with
obstruction for trying to prevent them
from testifying about him here is Adam
Schiff who again has a pup tent set up
at both MSNBC and CNN and doesn't
actually work for a living I should know
he's my representative in California
here's Adam chef we are going through
the witness transcripts right now
looking at Donald Trump juniors
testimony looking at your Kushner's
testimony looking at the testimony of
Felix aider and others to determine okay
what does this tell us about their
truthfulness what is what missing pieces
does this fill in mark Warner who is
senator from Virginia he says let's face
it you've got all these close associates
of the president one after another
pleading guilty often pleading guilty
about their ties to Russia and Russians
he said what are they covering up for
the reason Donald Trump jr. could be in
the crosshairs is because during his
appearance before the Senate Judiciary
Committee in September 2017 he was asked
about efforts to build Trump Tower
projects in Moscow and at that time he
was asked specifically about the deal
right senators discussed at least two
potential developments involving the
Trump's Trump jr. said one involving the
family's partners in this Universe
pageant I had to deal a fatigue by via
died of deal fatigue by the end of 2014
he said certainly not 2016 there's never
a definitive end to it the proposed deal
being worked by Cohen came soon after
Trump jr. said he knew very little about
the proposal court filings however
suggest members of trumps family were
looped into discussions about the
proposed deal referred to Trump as
individual one but that still doesn't
answer
how much Trump jr. knew right if he said
he knew very little about the proposal
other than he thought that Trump had
signed a letter of intent to pursue it
that may not in fact be lying all of
which is to say we still don't know what
Muller knows we still don't know what is
coming what we do know is that the
original claim in all of this the
original claim the powerful claim from
the very beginning is that President
Trump was colluding with the Russians
who hacked the election and the idea of
hacking the election meant that there
was an attempt by Trump to actively
collude with the Russians to weaponize
information hacking Hillary Clinton's
emails that his people were working with
the Russians to hack Hillary Clinton's
emails or that there was a quid pro quo
and Trump was going to give the Russian
something in exchange for going after
Hillary Clinton or something like that
none of that has yet been proven so
there are only a couple of paths that
seem a quote-unquote
teachable path number one Trump suborn
perjury he told Michael Cohen I need you
to go out I need you to lie to the
American people I need you to lie to
Congress I need you to actually commit a
crime right that would be path number
one suborning perjury is in fact a
federal crime that would probably be a
bit impeachable offense given the
president's the precedents of Bill
Clinton and Richard Nixon precedent
number two for impeachment would be if
Trump actually participated in some sort
of quid pro quo
be soft and maybe most plausible
scenarios that Trump had heard about all
of this stuff and that he was fibbing
about having heard about all of this
stuff is that impeachable probably not
is it devastating for Trump 2020 it's
certainly not good for Trump 2020 but
again we have yet to see the other shoe
drop and I'm happy to wait until the
other shoe drops because all of the
information will be forthcoming this is
not me kicking the can down the road
it's just we don't have enough
information yet so I'm not gonna jump to
conclusions okay in just a second I want
to talk about this horrifying report
about us
life expectancy plus I want to get to
Mark Lamont Hill who was fired from CNN
yesterday first let's talk about how you
defend yourself when the founders
crafted the Constitution the first thing
they did was make sacred the rights of
the individual the second thing they did
was make sure that you had a gun so he
could protect those rights you know how
strongly I believe in the Bill of Rights
in the Constitution you should too and
you know who does Bravo Company
manufacturing it started in a garage by
a Marine veteran more than two decades
ago to build a professional-grade
product that meets combat standards BCM
believes the same level of protection
should be provided to every American
regardless of whether they're a private
citizen or a professional BCM is not a
sporting arms company the design
engineer manufacture life-saving
equipment they assume every rifle
leaving their shop will be used in a
life-or-death situation so better work
every components of a BCM rifle is hand
assembled and tested by Americans to a
life-saving standard BCM feels a moral
responsibility as Americans to provide
tools that will not fail the user when
it's not just a paper target when it's
actually something real at stake to
learn more about Bravo company
manufacturing head on over to Bravo
Company MFG Khan again the folks there
are just amazing and you can see all of
their videos at youtube.com slash Bravo
Company USA that's Bravo Company MFG
comm check out their videos the folks
who run it the folks who created it the
folks who work there they're just
amazing people check it out youtube.com
slash Bravo Company USA and if you're
ready to buy something from them go
check out Bravo Company
FG comm they really are first-rate okay
so in media news Marc Lamont Hill has
now been fired from CNN he was fired for
a good reason because he went in front
of the UN in front of a bunch of
genocide all anti-jewish anti-semitic
countries and he said from the river to
the sea Palestine will be free okay that
is a Hamas slogan the slogan is that
Israel will be fully destroyed and that
all the Jews in the area will be killed
or expelled into the sea okay that is
literally what that means this is not a
dog whistle this is just saying stuff
out loud
that's not a dog whistle that's not
making a vague reference now mark Lamont
Hill tried to claim no I was just saying
human rights for everyone really that's
why you in front of with you and
justified terrorism against Israelis I
mean he literally did this and then he
went out and spouted a slogan that
receives wild applause from the Iranians
from the Palestinians from everyone who
wants to see the udin pushed into the
sea so Hill did all of this and it
sparked immediate backlash why because
it is a Hamas slogan okay so CNN
eventually so Lamont Hill then then
tweeted out he's not he's not
anti-semitic said I do not support
anti-semitism killing Jewish people or
any of the other things attributed to my
speech we didn't attribute it to your
speech you said it
it is not attributed it's just
anti-semitism and he said what I meant
by river to the sea was not a call to
destroy anything or anyone it was a call
for justice both in Israel and in the
West Bank Gaza this meets very clearly
and specifically said those things
actually the speech should not clearly
and specifically say any of those things
this is just a blatant attempt to
rewrite all of this stuff I mean this is
what he actually said at UN contrary to
Western mythology black resistance to
American apartheid did not compare Lilu
Gandhi and non-violence rather slave
revolts in self-defense and tactics
otherwise divergent from dr. King or
Mahatma Gandhi were equally important to
preserving safety in attaining freedom
if we are to operate in true solidarity
with the Palestinian people we must
allow the Palestinian people the same
range of opportunity and political
possibility okay so he's talking about
slave revolts and he's comparing that to
Palestinians committing acts of terror
and defending it so all of this is just
a lie and so CNN fired him
now this raised a lot of questions from
people about whether he ought to be
fired here is the rule on whether you
ought to be fired because we've had
several situations in which commentators
have said
things or tweeted things and then they
were fired so I defended the Roseann
firing the reason I defended the Roseann
firing at the time is because I said
that NBC did not have evidence that she
was a quote-unquote racist and then she
said something about Valerie Jarrett
that was on its face racist she is the
character NBC does not have to take a
million-dollar loss in order to keep
promoting a show that is going to get
destroyed in the ratings that is not
their responsibility went to the core
business
she said something unacceptable and it
was new material I said about Sarah's
wrong who's a columnist for The New York
Times that she should not in fact be
fired the reason was not because she
hadn't said terrible things in the past
it was because people dug up old stuff
she'd said in the past the New York
Times had hired her knowing all that
stuff was there and so there was no new
information being presented to the New
York Times it was just a social media
mobbing in the same way I defended James
Gunn right who had a bunch of old bad
tweets bad jokes about pedophilia and
such and I said Disney knew about this
at the time this is just a social media
mobbing so my basic rule is this private
companies first of all have a right to
do whatever they want number two if you
threaten the brand of the company the
company has a responsibility to its
shareholders to take you out number
three the question is whether a new
piece of information has been emergent
or whether this is just ginned up
outrage about a piece of old Twitter II
okay Marc Lamont Hill did something new
we knew the mark Lamont Hill did all
this stuff years ago if for example
people said you know Mark Lamont Hill
back in 2008 defended Louis Farrakhan
you should be fired
I've been probably not probably not and
I don't like Marc Lamont he'll I think
he's terrible but probably not but this
is a new thing that he did a new piece
of information so CNN not only had every
right to fire him this is a piece of
open anti-semitism now I have to tell
you it's unbelievable unbelievable how
exactly the folks on the Left have
covered the mahkumaat Hill statements
and it just demonstrates that for the
left as long as you say anti-semantic
things about Israel we pretend that it's
not anti-semitic hey the actual headline
from the Washington Post was this CNN
fires Marc Lamont Hill in wake of
remarks criticizing Israel and calling
for a free Palestine that is not why
they fired him they fired him because
what he said was anti-semitic it wasn't
that he was criticizing Israel and
calling for a free Palestine if you
actually want to quote
entire phrase quoth the entire phrase
this is just an outright lie there are
people who are in favor of a two-state
solution who say yeah we want a free
Palestine you know who would be among
those people members of the Israeli
cabinet who have called for a two-state
solution for nigh on 30 years it's not
gonna happen by the way because the
Palestinians don't want a two-state
solution but let's not Willimon Hill
said he said free Palestine from the
river to the sea the river meaning the
Jordan River the sea meaning the
Mediterranean Sea you know what's in the
middle of there that would be Israel
right there so he's talking about the
complete destruction of the State of
Israel
that's a blatantly anti-semitic
statement and the Washington Post covers
it as though it's just controversial not
really it's mostly just controversial no
not not anti-semetic person come on and
the hill does the exact same thing so
the hills headline was suggested
something like this is suggested exactly
the same thing that was just a
controversial statement the mark Lamont
Hill hadn't done anything truly terrible
he hadn't said anything anti-semitic it
was just you know a little weird it was
just a little weird
again the willingness of so many on the
left to overlook anti-semitism coming
from the left by saying well it's not
interests anti-israel it just shows you
that when people say I'm not answer
semantics I'm just anti-israel maybe
that's true but there has not yet been
an anti-semite who is not anti-israel I
mean they here's a here's the headline
from the hill CNN cuts ties with Marc
Lamont Hill after Israel comments they
didn't people make comments on Israel
all the time on CNN that is not exactly
what happened now contrast this media
coverage of Marc Lamont Hills comments
with the media coverage of Tucker
Carlson and you can see the double
standard so the same Washington Post
that said the Marco Mountain Hill was
only being criticized for being
anti-israel that same Washington Post
claimed yesterday the media critic Eric
wimple that Tucker Carlson of Fox News
was a neo-nazi favorite what proof do
they have that Tucker Carlson is a
neo-nazi or is complicit with neo-nazis
or is working with the neo-nazis they're
only proof is an article from BuzzFeed
talking about how the daily stormer
which is a neo-nazi website run by a
piece-of-crap named Andrew eggwin
featured articles about Tucker Carlson
like 265 times
wimple said where's a host like Hannity
for example for every parent's Trump's
talking points Carlson has consistently
pursued storylines and polemical
themes that please racists Karlsson
hypes alleged crimes and dislocation
caused by immigration he demands the
u.s. elites defend the cliche that
diversity is our greatest strength he
circulates bogus material about South
Africa's alleged injustice against white
farmers and he cheers Trump's hardline
immigration policies okay how any of
those things are our neo-nazi material
is beyond me but that didn't stop Eric
wimple from basically labeling Tucker
Carlson complicit and working with
neo-nazis for saying things that are
basically conservative / populist and
then lumping him in with Indian art so
let's just get this straight mark Lamont
Hill says the Jews should be killed
between the reverence eat when you say
pre Palestine from the river to the sea
you're talking about a you Dan Ryan area
called Palestine where no Jews live and
the destruction of the Jewish state as
an entity that according to the
Washington Post is just controversial
anti Israeli commentary Tucker Carlson
however for saying that he disapproves
illegal immigration and wonders whether
diversity is in fact strength or whether
we have to have some common set of
shared values that makes him a neo-nazi
the media bias when it comes to the the
accounts of particular viewpoints is
truly astonishing truly truly
astonishing ok in just a second I want
to talk about a couple of controversies
with regard to Twitter and then the war
story of the day but first let's talk
about how you can save on your
healthcare coverage did you ever make a
change and wonder yourself why didn't I
do this a long time ago that's what's
happening with thousands of people with
regard to their health care they're
joining Medicare and they're asking
themselves why didn't I do this earlier
Medicare is based on the biblical
principles of caring for and sharing and
one another's needs as such Medicare is
more than healthcare it's a community of
believers who share one another's health
care costs and even pray for each other
Medicare is exactly what I've always
talked about when you talk about the
formation of community and social fabric
to take care of one another this is what
Medicare does in a way that saves you
money it's growing like crazy they have
four hundred thousand members to give
you an idea of the savings the typical
Medicare family saves five hundred bucks
a month it's a lot of money what do they
do
well basically they're making sure that
if god forbid something catastrophic
happens to you in terms of health that
you are now covered and that that cost
is shared among this community of
believers and again every time you have
a health care problem you legitimately
have people
writing to you if you're a member of
Medicare and talking about how they're
praying for you seeing what they can do
for you on a charitable basis as well
since its inception in 1993 members have
shared more than one point nine billion
dollars in medical expenses Medicare
works and has another bonus which is you
don't have to pay for things that you
don't believe in so you're not buying
insurance from a typical insurance
company and the money is going to cover
abortion coverage so do something you
believe in and save a lot of money to
boot this is one of those why did you
wait on it things here's your chance to
join in call eight four four six one
Bible that's eight four four sixty one
Bible or go to Medicare comm /ban that's
Medicare comm slash been again 844
sixty-one Bible I can't recommend
Medicare highly enough to people who are
Christian believers if you are a
Christian and you are looking for health
care coverage and you're looking for a
community and a social fabric to pick
you up
and you want to save money on your
health insurance this is the best way to
do it go to Medicare comm /ban that is
Medicare calm /ban eight four four sixty
one Bible again eight four four sixty
one Bible go check it out right now
fantastic option particularly for young
families it really is quite terrific
okay so I want to get into a Twitter
controversy and the worst story of the
day and the mailbag we got a lot coming
up but you're gonna have to go over to
daily wire.com and subscribe 99 999 a
month gets you the rest of my show live
the rest of Andrew Clavin shall add the
rest Michael Mills shall live you want
to ask me a question in the mailbag well
you totally can but I'm not gonna answer
it unless you pay me
that's why you need $9.99 a month that
subscription also coming up Monday
December 3rd don't miss our next episode
of daily wire backstage Holiday Edition
god king small G small K jeremy boring
will join me as well as the awful
michael knowles and andrew Clavin will
discuss holidays politics culture have
left wounds all of them be sure to tune
in as always lovely alicia crafts will
be classing up the place taking your
questions live as they roll in only
daily where subscribers get to ask the
questions so make sure that you
subscribe today hey i'm gonna be
spending my next December third doing
this thing
so show up come on if I'm gonna waste my
evening that way you better be there
also don't miss Andrew Clayton's next
chapter of another Kingdom performed by
the mediocre Michael Knowles today we'll
be live-streaming the first 15 minutes
of episode eight titles the darkest hour
aka the Moller investigation head on
over to daily we're calm and subscribe
to watch the full episode and get early
access to upcoming episodes every single
Monday wouldn't you get all of these
fantastic things also when you get the
annual
option n you get this the most envied
the most desired the most sought-after
commodity on the open market today but
there is a limited supply you can only
just one get 99 999 dollars a year you
get the annual subscription you get this
the leftist here's hot or cold temblor
cast your eyes upon the glory of this
vessel and know that you could be
enjoying this if only if only you could
scrape together the measly $99 to get
our annual subscription which comes with
all those great benefits and you get to
sip these leftist tears every single day
so go check that out right now also
please view us on YouTube or iTunes
please subscribe and leave us review
have so many good Sunday specials coming
up we do all this for you all this for
you and all we ask is that you spend
money on us and treat us well like you
would a spouse and that you and that you
commit to us for the long term and that
you leave us a nice review and give us
compliments you know the way that you
would a spouse that's all we ask of you
really not much when you think about it
we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so yesterday
in other news Laura Loomer what he'd
been banned from Twitter the reason that
she'd been banned from Twitter is
because she tweeted something out about
the evils of radical Islam and she did
something that I thought was actually
quite good for the most part and then
she blew it with with some of her
publicity ploy so she changed herself to
the Twitter headquarters to drop
publicity totally fine with this this
Anor it's a form of protest she's
totally fine doing and she pasted above
the Twitter doorway a couple of
competing tweets one from Louis
Farrakhan which has not gotten louis
farrakhan ban and says i'm not an
anti-semite i'm anti termite foremost
Farrakhan and she just opposed that with
her own tweet which said something like
isn't it ironic how the Twitter moment
used to celebrate women LGBTQ and
minorities is a picture of Ilhan Omar
right Ilhan Omar is the the Minnesota
representative who is Pro BDS she says
she is a pro Shariah and she is pro FGM
female genital mutilation the reason she
says that is because ohan Omar is one of
the four members of the Minnesota
Legislature who voted against a bill
banning female genital mutilation in the
state of Minnesota under Sharia
homosexuals are oppressed and killed
women are abused and forced to wear the
hijab and Ilhan is anti-jewish that that
is Laura la mercè we choose band for
that tweet there's nothing in that tweet
that is remotely Manorville nothing is
remotely Manipal about that tweet and
she is correct to point out the
hypocrisy here now she didn't make one
crucial mistake okay in terms of
publicity if she had done that everyone
is totally on her side on the right
instead what she decided to do was that
and also she decided to wear a Jewish
star that said you didn't on it you I'm
sorry being banned from Twitter is not
the same thing as being a member of the
Jewish population in the Warsaw Ghetto
in 1943 not the same thing okay it's not
the same thing he's being crowded into a
concentration camp like let's let's not
go there and this is part of the problem
is that how you get out your message is
just as important as the message in many
ways more important than the message
she's totally right she shouldn't have
been banned Louis Farrakhan should be
banned and the fact that she has
basically and when I say Louis Farrakhan
should be banned I'm not even sure
that's the case maybe it was Farrakhan
shouldn't be banned maybe she should
stay on Twitter I'm actually okay with
that I want people to know what lose
Farrakhan thinks but certainly Laura
Loomer
not have been banned and Twitter is
trying to purge people that doesn't like
but also don't wear Jewish stars that
are reminiscent of the Holocaust because
he got banned from a social media
platform that is not the same thing it
just isn't
okay so meanwhile the greatest piece of
news this week again it gives the lie to
the idea that despair and upset in
America are driven by the economy here's
the story
life is expectancy in the United States
dropped yet again as drug overdoses
continued to climb take more than 70,000
lives in 2017 and suicides rose again a
US government report said Thursday the
drug overdose rate rose nine point six
percent compared to 2016 suicides
climbed three point seven percent
according to the US Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention's National Center
for Health Statistics as a result the
average life span in America dropped to
seventy eight point six years a decrease
of zero point one year from 2016 this is
the second straight year in which life
expectancy in the United States has
dropped after rising consistently for
legitimately a hundred years if this is
a serious crisis but it is not an
economic crisis what I'm seeing from a
lot of folks is well this is because
there are the economically dispossessed
this does not work the reason this does
not work is suicide rates are now higher
than they were I believe during the
Great Depression certainly drug
overdoses are a lot higher than they
were during the Great Depression things
were a lot worse than we've had
significantly worse economies even
you'll have to go back to the Great
Depression go back to 2008-2009 the life
expectancy did not drop in 2008-2009 in
the fact that life expectancy has
dropped yet again is an indicator that
there is something missing in the
American soul that we have destroyed our
own social fabric that we have atomized
ourselves into these little not even
groups into basically polarized marbles
walking around the world suspicious of
everybody around us they have no values
that we hold in common that we feel
threatened that we feel empty that we're
looking for something if we don't have
shared values if we don't have social
fabric if we don't have community if we
don't know what America is about or what
we're doing in the world if we don't
have purpose and meaning it makes it
almost impossible to live a fulfilled
life I say this because I have a new
book that's coming out and I'm not just
pitching the book I have a new book
coming out next year that is
specifically about this what were the
shared values of the West that built the
West and how have we lost those things
we live in a time of unprecedented
material prosperity a time of
precedented personal freedom and yet
life expectancy is dropping in the
United States that is happening because
there is a god-shaped hole in the
American heart there's a a crisis of
what you're supposed to do when you get
up in the morning you know we've been
promoting empty nostrils like go make
the world a better place
okay this presupposes a couple of things
what one what is a better place to that
you have the capacity to make the world
a better place but at the same time we
have been telling people you don't
actually have the capacity to make the
world a better place you're nothing more
than a ball of meat wandering around
aimlessly in the universe without free
will and also social forces are
organized against you so why in the
world should you go out there and try
and - we've not to find what better
looks like okay if better it just means
material prosperity then why are the
suicide rates going up better always
meant spiritual fulfillment but we don't
have spiritual fulfillment in a time
when we have cast the spirit out we have
no spiritual fulfillment in a time when
we have decided that God family
community the very basics the very
basics of what it means to be a
fulfilled human being over the course of
human history all those things are
irrelevant the only thing that matters
is virtue signaling politics rage
showing other people how much you care
about things and despair despair because
obviously you're not in control of your
own life this is why you know so much of
my message is concentrated around what
can you do in your life to make your
life better you want to make your life
better
go do it and if there's an obstacle then
let's talk about the obstacle but if you
are spending all your life focused on
everything around you and why it's bad
and you're doing that because you lack a
sense of purpose you're not gonna be
happy you're going to despair you're
gonna feel like there's no one there to
pick you up we all have to be together
to pick ourselves up and I don't mean
through government I mean through shared
values and shared community and a social
fabric built up over the course of three
thousand years of judeo-christian
history it's it's this is tragic tragic
stuff okay let's do a little bit of the
mailbag like John says hey Ben I want to
ask you to elaborate on why you think
Marbury was wrongly decided and judicial
review is not the role of the Supreme
Court I'm not too knowledgeable in this
area I've never heard this argument
before and it seems pretty interesting
any thoughts would be great thanks so
the basic idea here is that if you read
the Federalist Papers as we do every
week what the founders envision is that
all of the branches would check one
another the judiciary would check the
executive the executive would check the
legislative the legislative would check
the
the judiciary and all of the rest making
the Supreme Court the final purview of
constitutional adjudication prevents a
final check from taking place it means
that only the Supreme Court has the
purview of interpreting what the
Constitution means we vary oaths that
people take upon taking office in the
United States Congress or upon taking
office in the presidency is to uphold
protect defend the Constitution of the
United States their interpretations
matter just as much as the judiciary's
interpretation of the Constitution so
the idea that the judiciary can say what
the Constitution is and use that to
strike down laws seems to me a wild
misrepresentation of what the judiciary
it was meant to do there is nothing in
the Constitution itself that says that
you the judiciary gets to take a law
from the legislature hold it up against
the Constitution of the United States or
an action of the executive as in the
case of Marbury vs. Madison and then
strike down that action
it actually takes power away from the
American people and it removes
responsibility from the American people
to vote for politicians will uphold the
Constitution instead we sort of
outsourced it to the judiciary and then
pretend that the judiciary is a
non-political implement now the case
against me is that in Federalist 78
Alexander Hamilton talks about judicial
review a little bit he talks about the
idea that the judiciary is there to
interpret the law and should the
judiciary become a political body rather
than anything else then it would stop
fulfilling its its purpose okay but
that's exactly what it's done right
because the judiciary has been given the
power to interpret the Constitution it's
become a political tool sole power means
authoritarianism from any branch Jacob
says dear future Chief Justice Shapiro
I'm proposing my girlfriend I've known
for 10 years next Saturday any words of
wisdom on how not to screw it up well
how not to screw it up well first of all
when you say you're proposing your
girlfriend we have to determine which
sort of proposal we're talking about do
you know she's gonna say yes or is this
an actual proposal so I have this whole
thing about how you see people and
they're like oh you know I'm gonna stop
my my beautiful proposal story I'm gonna
go and I'm gonna rent a blimp and it'll
right across the sky will you marry me
Charlene and most of the time the answer
is already yes right you're just doing
this for like a big shows he can tell
all your friends I don't like those
proposal stories I think they're BS I
think that the thing that is important
is the original time you asked the
question and
the original time you asked the question
you know the the question is why she has
not committed heretofore if the real
question is how do you convince her then
the answer should be obvious which is
you commit to her you say listen I want
to give you the rest of my life that's
what I want I want to give you the rest
of my life and I want to partner with
you in this journey you're the person
that I choose to be my partner in this
journey to create a family to create the
fundamental building block of site to
share values to be with until I die
because you know things are going to be
great and things are gonna be tough
but because we believe in the same
things and we share the same soul then
we should be together so just transcribe
that then say it or andrew says hey Ben
I used to disagree with you about my
parent about parents staying together
for the sake of the children even if
they want a divorce my parents are still
together for 33 years but it's clear
they are deeply unhappy in any event I
have a friend who has had six children
in eight years with his wife now he's
talking about leaving even though he
said he'd still take care of his kids I
told him it was too late to back out now
he disagreed so we had a friendly
argument by the end I was fully
advocating an agreeing with your
position on the subject I was surprised
to see how quickly my thoughts on the
subject changed through the course of a
single conversation have you had an
experience where your mind was rapidly
and unexpectedly changed on a subject if
not what has been the fastest amounts of
time you've changed your mind on
something well new evidence tends to
change my mind
yeah and usually changing your mind like
I think that even in the course of this
conversation Andrew it wasn't the
conversation to change your mind I think
that you had heard this opinion
articulated many times the one you ended
up at many times and this was the final
straw that broke the camel's back the
art of persuasion is not trying to
convince someone in one conversation
it's building up a case a case a case
and then finally there's a piece of
evidence that breaks the camel's back
and that's how you end up at that
position that happens to me on a fairly
frequent basis my guess is that that's
what happened to you here kevin says
what are we gonna do about the robots
automation we thought of hominis our
autonomous weapons drones machine
learning taking jobs etc well big
question my basic thing is I think that
we are the ones who set the parameters
for the machines if we're not setting
parameters on lethal weaponry with
self-learning capacity then we don't we
wouldn't like Skynet but I'm really not
that worried about technology taking
jobs because every technology ever
created has created more prosperity and
more jobs over the course of time Steven
says hi Ben I'm considering visiting
Israel any tips or suggestions for
things to do or places to visit thanks I
love your show
Israel's an amazing country you should
try to you know see as much as you can
top to bottom it's also an incredibly
small country so you can actually do
this
everybody visits Jerusalem which of
course you should I'm not like that keen
on visiting Tel Aviv Tel Aviv is
basically just like any other American
city so I don't think that you gain all
that much from Tel Aviv per se if you're
looking for sort of the culture of
Israel I would recommend that you go to
spot which is the mystical city in
Israel Safed then the mystical city in
Israel is pretty fantastic Akko with
acre which is a historic site in terms
of Israeli history for the Crusades it
was obviously historic site as well
that's well worth seeing you should go
see Judea and Samaria if you can you
should go out to see efrat which is in a
Jewish settlement so you can see what a
settlement actually looks like you
should go up to Russian incra which is
at the top of Israel go look over the
border at Lebanon see how close
everything is you should go see the
Golan Heights so you can see that when
people talk about Israel giving up the
Golan Heights they're absolutely out of
their damned minds now you should but
Israel is so fantastic because you can
see all of these things in the course of
just a few days and go see all the
historic sites go see the site where
David fought Goliath go see the valley
it's really it's just it's an amazing
amazing place Ashley says what is your
opinion of genetic engineering from a
moral and policy standpoint thanks
Ashley well I think that genetic
engineering is appropriate when you are
attempting to avoid disease it is not
appropriate when you are attempting to
better the child more than nature would
so for example if you are selecting for
let's say we have the capacity select
for higher IQ than we could normally
select for I'm not a big fan of this
idea I'm not a big fan of this idea
because now you're getting into basic
eugenics however if we're talking about
if you could just tweak the genetic code
and prevent hey Sachs for example to
prevent suffering then I think that that
would be something worthwhile it's the
difference between sort of optional
surgery and non optional surgery I in
the in II post birth world and I'm
generally not a huge fan of non optional
surgery you know if you're just getting
a surgery because you want your tummy to
look a little bit better I don't think
that it's like tremendously immoral but
I don't think it's good when you're
talking about actively changing how
someone's entire life will go I think
that you're looking at immorality and
handing a power to a doctor that that
doctor should not have
but if you talk about a cancer surgery
obviously that's necessary if you're
talking my preventing cancer in a baby
that's necessary getting rid of a BRCA
gene or something if you if you're
talking about the possibility of
changing the eye color of a kid this
gets into I think really dangerous
territory where you're genetically
engineering kids to create some sort of
master race brad says hi been my
genetics uses books like the big lie or
death mination
historically accurate um parts yes part
no I would say I think that dinesh I'm
trying I have read the Big Y I have not
so death mination there's a lot there
that is historically accurate I think
that Dinesh overshoots his case a little
bit in some of these books I think that
he uses an exaggerated form of the case
like the idea that that the Nazis
learned everything they needed to know
about eugenics from the Democrats I just
it was a worldwide eugenic movement and
the Democrats were part of it and so
were the Nazis I think the idea the
Democrats are you know the greatest
force against human freedom and that all
the other bad guys learn from the
Democrats I have some problems with that
I think you can argue that the Democrats
were a force against human freedom and
for eugenics and for human rights
violations in the nineteen 1900s 1910s
1920s 1930s you know I think all of
that's true but I think exaggerating the
case is not particularly necessary Casey
and by the way I like to not remember
I'm friendly with tonight Casey says
hello Ben
when my discussions of pro-choice
individuals the question that I always
seem to get hung up on is what about the
after care of women who no longer have
abortions if we managed to sway the
country to where abortions no longer
happened what would you recommend or
what are your thoughts on how we would
take care of the women that are no
longer having abortions and may wear it
very well be single parents I really
enjoy your opinions and podcast okay
this is the last question so my so I
think that we don't focus enough on the
on the amazing thing that adoption is I
think we need to focus on the courage of
people who take adopted babies it is a
courageous thing take a baby who is not
born of your genetics and to try and
raise that child I have too many friends
who have adopted and I see what they go
through depending on who the kid is and
I see that they love these children as
much as their own genetic children if
they have both these are amazing people
taking an adopted kid is basically the
greatest thing that you can do in this
life I think and beyond that I think
that a mother who has the courage to see
that her child
needs a mother and a father and is
willing to make the emotional sacrifice
of giving up her own child to a better
situation knowing that a better
situation exists that's an act of
courage as well and women who do that
instead of killing the baby in the womb
those women should absolutely be
celebrated okay time for it some things
I like and then some things that I hate
so things that I like I do love this so
pay less payless shoes they opened up a
pop-up store and they called the the
pop-up store policy PA el es si and it
is spectacular so here's what they did
Payless opened a fake pop-up store
called policy and in la mall and invited
an influencers to the grand opening the
store was stocked with payless shoes in
disguise a woman in a TV ad was holding
a pair of $20 sneakers and she said I
would pay 400 or 500 dollars for these
sneakers another shopper called the
payless shoes elegant and sophisticated
the stunt even included a sleek website
and an Instagram account about 80
influencers attended over two nights
according to pay less they shelled out a
total of three thousand dollars one
shopper spent six hundred forty dollars
for a pair of boots
which represented in $1,800 and 1800
percent markup Payless returned their
money and let them keep the shoes palest
said the influencers were paid a small
stipend to attend so paleis said that
this social experiment was meant to
remind shoppers that pay less is
affordable shoes are fashionable as well
what it actually reminds people is
there's a lot of social science research
to back this up people don't just buy
things because they think that those
things are nicer so they pay a more
expensive price people on the upper end
buy things that are expensive because
they think that the price itself
dictates the quality of the product they
think that a product that is identical
but cost more must be nicer because
we've all learned that if people are
willing to pay more for something that
means that it's nicer so you will see
retailers who will actually retail
things for an extraordinary markup
particularly in the fashion industry
where taste is subjective and then
because it's really expensive people
think that it's better people think that
it's nicer and so the markup in the
fashion industry is really really strong
this is why competition is so necessary
but could patently here's the thing
could pay less II have gotten away with
this in indefinitely no because what
would have happened over time well we've
happened over time and somebody what
about a Payless pair of shoes for 20
bucks and then
presumably after three weeks when the
palest pair of shoes starts to fall
apart for example when these boots
don't hold up the way an actual $640
pair of boots hold up
then the reviews start coming in on
Payless e-comm and on amazon.com and
people begin to realize that these boots
are not worth it and the place goes out
of business this is why people
misunderstand fraud and capitalism well
you know capitalism it leads to fraud
people into fraud people capitalism is a
it's it's a repeat iteration game okay
so there are many iterations in
capitalism if you are it's true you can
meet a fraud if you're buying a singular
thing one time but if you have lots of
people over time buying lots of things
then eventually people start to actually
critique particularly in an area or
social media is active people can
actually critique the product over time
and realize that these boots are
actually not as nice as the boots that
are more expensive and then we find out
but this actually means we have to do
our research it's why it's good that
there are review sites that's why it's
good that people are able to get
feedback online and it's why people tend
to trust that feedback online over time
okay let's say let's do a quick thing I
hate I'll save the the other thing that
I like for next week so things that I
hate one thing that drives me absolutely
up a wall is Neil deGrasse Tyson's
science so listen I love science science
is fantastic right I'm a huge science
fan I like evidence I like science what
I don't like is when people suggest that
science is a category that rules
everything that you can determine
morality from science you cannot you
cannot determine or ality from science
yeah this is Sam Harris his argument I
think it completely fails Neil deGrasse
Tyson does something else he basically
says what I believe is science what you
believe is anti science so here's what
he tweeted out yesterday and it is just
dumb he tweeted out a picture of the
news the new robot that has landed on
Mars and is taking pictures which is
super cool by the way it is pretty
amazing I mean we put a machine 300
million miles away on a planet and it's
taking pictures and sending them back to
us we're the first human beings in
history to have ever seen pictures like
this in any case here's what he tweeted
scientists and engineers launched
insight from Earth a moving platform
across three hundred million miles to
arrive for Mars a moving target will be
seven months later landing
safely to do geophysics at the Martian
equator and you have a problem listening
to us about climate change okay two
things one NASA engineers are good at
what they do they're modeling is good it
worked you know we know it's good
because it worked when it comes to
climate change all of the modeling so
far has been wrong so if you were to say
like I could apply the same exact
standard to scientists created the
Challenger it blew up on improve on
takeoff should we trust those people
with climate change like this is not
because you were competent at this thing
does not mean that you are competent at
this thing particularly when they are in
separate areas of science right this JPL
NASA this is all physics
yeah that's not quite the same thing as
climate physics or climatology which has
a lot of factors the modeling has not
been proper and all the rest okay also
the the idea that because I have a
problem with your solutions on climate
change I therefore have a problem with
your science on climate changes nonsense
everything I've ever said about climate
change is cribbed from the IPCC report
when I talk about the range of
variability of the climate over the next
hundred years when I talk about the
levels of certainty of that variability
I am I'm quoting from the reports that
Neil deGrasse Tyson likes I'm quoting
from the federal reports when I talked
earlier this week about the 10%
reduction in GDP that's supposed to
happen over the next hundred years and I
pointed out that that was double the RCP
eight point five the highest risk
scenario when I said that that is from
the report I am NOT making that up I'm
trusting the scientist but Neil deGrasse
Tyson basically says you should listen
to me on everything because some other
scientist who is not me did something
that is not climate science this is
science is not fungible
hey you can't actually do that that's
not how this works really really stupid
stuff from the only grass Tyson but
again I don't it's stupidity just
because you're a scientist doesn't mean
you don't say dumb things from time to
time and you'll deGrasse Tyson's Twitter
account is filled with some dumb things
okay we will be back here next week I'm
sure there will be many more updates on
everything Russia and Mullah related
you're gonna want to stay tuned to trump
season four it's pretty spectacular I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing